please welcome a professor from
university of amherst
sandy litchfield
thank you brady i'm happy to be here
uh so i work as an artist and a curator
and an assistant professor associate
professor sorry i just got tenure
at
university of massachusetts and amherst
i teach courses that lie at the
intersection of art architecture design
and writing
this project began in response to a
series of questions first if mistakes
are gifts we give ourselves to learn
then what will we learn collectively
from the mistakes that we as a
civilization are making now
and what will civilization even look
like in a thousand years
finally how can artists writers
scientists and other informed
imaginarians come together and help
shape a future in which civilization is
understood as a fully entwined
terrestrial entity
on distinct keys is a transdisciplinary
platform for generating speculative
futures in the wake of climate change
with a virtual twist and playful shake
it attempts to confront and reckon with
the precarious nature of our planet's
future
as sea levels rise and coastal shores
flood on distinct keys imagines the
birth and rise of a new baby island
the island begins as a volcanic sea
mount deep in the north atlantic
in a massive volcanic eruption the sea
mount breaks the ocean's surface in the
year 2066.
life shows up pretty quickly after that
and within a thousand years of evolution
there are rivers and lakes settlements
and cities and forests and farms
now in this future tale places are the
main characters
they are sentient beings that have
rights
and they are intricately entwined with
all the organic and mineral elements
that inhabit it including humans animals
insects
tree moss and stone
the stories emerge from a practice
called futuring
so what is futuring
futuring is an informed act of the
imagination
it is plural there is not one feature
there are many
it is democratic and inclusive of many
voices from around the world
featuring is also playful it's open and
it's adaptable
um but it's at the same time very
analytical and aware it collects and
analyzes information from the past
present to create stories about possible
probable and preferred futures
the process of featuring and now allows
for the intuitive it emphasizes the
atmospheric and the ambient over
certainty and solution
this essential ambiguity
maintains a kind of mystery in the
process
the project has two platforms for
storytelling there's the fabula which is
a future fiction set in the year 3000
and the chronica which is a diagrammatic
timeline that extends from 1000 to 3000
ce
the fabula is a non-linear narrative
that is more poetic and spatial and it
takes the form as of a map depicting
this future island called andaka
the chronica
which is a word that comes from kronos
which means the personification of time
is a more linear and sequential mode of
storytelling
now when you're piecing together
past and future events in a timeline
you would think that the past events
would be much more
evident and objective than the future
ones
but actually they're both stories with
various degrees of data and facts to
support them
even the present is a story that we
construct from our perceptions our
observations and our interpretations of
what is both known and unknown
this project seeks to uncover those
stories by assembling a diverse team of
scholars artists designers writers and
activists who engage in this practice of
featuring
here we tell stories
by listening to our past and future
selves the future island
the future ocean the future river
we draw pictures and we tell stories of
our becoming
how shall we become the lake
and the forest
how shall we become the city that lives
with the forest and the ocean and the
whale
and how can we extend the notion of
civility
to include the ecosystem
as the orchard watesy describes
it's an unreasonable season
full of reckless pollination
but if this feverish field of folly can
inoculate the poppy with a veritable
palm
you will find the nerve to stand at the
edge of green
and go
thank you
thank you sandy
using fiction has always been a great
way to make the future what's your
favorite sci-fi or future looking book
um i really like ursula k le guins
always coming home
um and i also like octavia butler's
parable of the sewer those are really my
two favorite
thank you very much for being with us
today cindy
you